[Narrator:] This film presents the neurological
examination of infants in the first week of life.
In most instances the normal responses are
followed by examples
of various types of abnormality which may
be encountered.
...when remarks seem needed.
This is clearly only one scheme of examination.
The sequence in which the tests are done will
of necessity vary somewhat from baby to baby,
depending on initial state.
In some cases, other examinations not included
here may need to be added.
Secondly, the matter of interpretation is
beyond the scope of a film of this length.
In only a few instances are abnormalities
clearly diagnostic or indicative for treatment.
Other abnormalities may clearly be deviations
from normal at the time, but may be transient,
and may be followed by entire future normality
of the baby.
In many cases, our present state of medical
knowledge does not permit us either
to explain the abnormality or give a prediction
prognostically for the future.
[Narrator:] Many items of examination must be evaluated by observation of the infant at rest,
preferably with minimal handling.
The head is observed for the position of the
eyes at rest.
Spontaneous movements of the face are observed,
and the palpebral fissures checked
for width and equality.
One abnormality to be looked for is the setting
sun sign.
As in this case of kernicterus, which consists of the [?] appearing to set beneath the lower lid,
so that white sclera may be seen between the
iris and the upper lid.
Unequal palpebral fissures may be the most
obvious physical sign of facial paralysis,
if the infant is not actively moving the face.
This example is a rather drowsy infant with
neonatal meningitis.
The Marcus Gunn phenomenon consists of congenital
ptosis, in which the lid
is automatically elevated each time the jaw
is moved in sucking.
Spontaneous movements of the body as a whole
and of the limbs are observed.
The character of the movements and the range
of motion of the joints should be appraised.
One should look for possible abnormal movements,
including tremulousness,
spontaneous writhing movement, myoclonus,
or convulsions.
In Werdnig Hoffman disease the baby is flaccid
and areflexic.
Respirations show bulging of the abdomen and
refraction of the chest.
Birth injury of the spinal cord superficially
resembles Werdnig Hoffman Disease.
The abnormal posture of the arms is the most
obvious difference, aside from other responses
to be demonstrated later.
The posture of the arms alongside the head is often one of the most initially striking features of mongolism.
Irregular jerking, writhing movements are
characteristic of many normal premature infants.
The earliest observed fetal activity is often
athetotic in nature.
And this type of movement appears to persist
for a time after premature birth.
Jittery, tremulous activity may be seen spontaneously
or may be obtained in response
to almost any stimulus.
Handling, sound, light, or eliciting the moro
reflex
may show the tremulous movements.
Unlike jitteriness, myoclonus is always an
abnormal spontaneous movement.
In this example the pathologic basis is obscured.
Although the infant was subsequently microcephalic,
with spastic diplegia,
the baby remained fully conscious and had
a normal electroencephalogram.
This is an example of convulsive movements
in an unconscious baby
with abnormal electroencephalogram.
Neonatal convulsions are usually based on
trauma or anoxia at birth,
or on chemical abnormalities.
The causation in this case is obscure, but
the disease was familial and presumably metabolic,
although no abnormal substance could be identified
in the urine.
Abnormal posture of the left arm is obvious
in this case of brachial palsy.
However, it is not complete, as some movement
can be obtained in response to pinprick.
The blink reflex to light is tested with a
Welch Allyn light or a strong flashlight.
Blinking should be obtained even if the baby's
eyes are closed, unless the baby is crying,
so that the eyes are already held maximally
closed.
An absent blink reflex seldom indicates blindness,
cortical or ocular.
More often, as in this example, it is due
to general depression of the central nervous system.
from anesthesia, anoxia or other causes.
Response to sound is tested with a wooden
clacker.
The response obtained may consist of a blink,
a startled jump, or a moro reflex.
This response is particularly hard to obtain
in many instances and should be repeated
before one concludes that it is missing.
Palmar grasping is tested by applying the
examiner's finger firmly against the palm
of the hand from the ulnar side.
The Palmar grasp response may be absent for
a variety of reasons,
including Werdnig Hoffman disease, as in this
example.
Plantar grasp is similarly tested,
applying the finger to the sole of the foot
near the base of the toes.
The knee jerk is the only tendon reflex of
major clinical value in most newborns.
It is tested in the conventional manner, but
the head should be in the midline
at the time of testing.
The knee jerk may be absent, as in this case
of Werdnig Hoffman disease,
or from central nervous system depression,
due to anoxia or other causes.
An exaggerated knee jerk is seen in this baby
with myoclonus.
Ankle clonus is best tested by pushing lightly
against the sole of the foot,
the entire leg being free in the air.
Often none is obtained, but a considerable
number of beats may be elicited
in many normal infants.
The average number of beats obtained should
be recorded.
This baby shows ankle clonus, which is sustained
for 8 or 10 beats,
but nevertheless turned out to be entirely
normal.
Slower, more vigorous ankle clonus of greater amplitude is sustained indefinitely in this baby
with generalized myoclonus.
The rooting response is tested by touching
each corner of the mouth and the upper and lower lip in the midline.
The infant's head will normally follow in
each direction, but sometimes movement
of the face and tongue only is obtained.
This reflex may be reinforced by previous
testing of the sucking reflex if necessary.
Sucking is tested with the examiner's finger
in the infant's mouth,
the finger being covered with a fingertop
for sterility.
An absent rooting response and very feeble
sucking are seen in this case
of congenital Werdnig Hoffman disease.
Another case of Werdnig Hoffman disease still
active with incomplete atrophy
shows a visibly fasciculating tongue.
The fasciculation is often most easily seen
on the undersurface of the tongue.
Normally, when an infant is picked up and
placed in the prone position with the head in the midline,
the baby will lift up its chin, turn the head
to one side, and make crawling movements with the feet,
and sometimes with the hands as well.
The arm may be extended on the side toward
which the head turns.
Vertical eye movements may be evaluated by
moving the head upward or downward.
The eyes tend to remain fixed toward the examiner,
in a manner rather like
the eyes of a doll.
To test the lobefin reflex the examiner holds
the baby vertically facing him
and turns first in one direction, then in
the other.
The effect can best be illustrated with the
research apparatus,
which rotates baby and camera together at
the same speed.
During rotation the baby looks ahead in the
direction of rotation.
On stopping, the infant looks back in the
opposite direction.
Sometimes only forced deviation of the eyes
is seen.
But nystagmus is usually observed in vigorous
mature infants.
Reptonic neck reflex is tested by turning
the child's head slowly to the right or left,
and maintaining it in this position for about
half a minute.
The shoulders should be kept horizontal.
A positive response consists of extension
of the arm and leg on the side toward which
the jaw is turned and flexion of the opposite
limbs.
There may be pelvic rotation in addition.
No constant pattern is obtained in the majority
of newborns, whether normal or not.
This baby, who subsequently turned out to
be entirely normal, shows fairly consistent
tonic neck reflexes, particularly in the legs.
Even these are not obtained on every occasion
however, and repeated rotation
of the head is necessary to evaluate the response.
This drawing illustrates a strong obligatory
response which the infant
cannot overcome by struggling.
This is abnormal at any age.
The traction response is tested by lifting
the infant from the supine position by pulling on his arms.
There should be assistance from the baby's
shoulder muscles, which can be felt
by the examiner.
When the infant is nearly to the sitting position,
the head should be brought forward and there
should be
sufficient tone in the neck muscles to keep
it from dangling helplessly against the chest
at the end of the test.
The traction response may be absent for a
variety of reasons,
as in this case of congenital Werdnig Hoffman
disease.
In mongolism the traction response is also
missing.
The universal hypertonia becomes evident in
testing this response.
An asymmetric traction response, absent on
the paralyzed side,
is seen in a left-sided brachial palsy.
The withdrawal response is tested by applying
a pin to the sole of the foot.
Facial evidence of pain should also be looked for, as failure to withdraw the stimulated limb
may be due to either anesthesia or paralysis.
The pin should be applied rather forcefully,
as a gentle pinprick may elicit a response of extension
rather than withdrawal.
This baby with Werdnig Hoffman disease shows
no withdrawal to pinprick.
But there's clear evidence of pain in the
facial expression.
An automatic jerky withdrawal is seen in this
baby with spinal cord injury.
There is no evidence of appreciation of pain
until the upper level of anesthesia is reached.
A striking crossed extension reflex in the
opposite limb may be seen
in many cases of spinal cord injury.
The tonic neck reflex may modify crossed extension.
Automatic withdrawal and lack of appreciation of pain are clear in this other case of cord injury.
The suggestion of crossed extension is only
obtained when the infant is supported
in the upright posture.
Spontaneous stepping movements may be obtained
in most infants if one supports them erect,
placing the soles of the feet firm on the
surface and inclining the trunk and head forward,
or intermittently from side to side.
Most mature infants show these stepping movements
at one time or another,
but not on every occasion.
To test the placing response, the infant is
again supported in the erect position and the dorsum
of first one foot and then the other is drawn
upward against the undersurface of the table edge.
The baby should lift its foot upward and place
it firmly on the table surface.
The placing reflex is poor and feeble in this
baby, but he is quite normal except for being fatigued.
from a long examination.
The placing response was vigorous on another
occasion.
The trunk incurvation reflex can be tested
by stroking the paravertebral areas.
It can also be evoked by pinching the skin
just above the pelvic brim.
The moro response can be tested in a variety
of ways, but is most reliable and most complete
when elicited by supporting the baby under
back and head, and letting the head drop back
about 30 degrees.
Normally the arms first extend and then flex.
The femora also flex on the pelvis in most
cases.
An absent moro reflex may be due to Werdnig
Hoffman disease
or more often to depression of the central
nervous system.
An abnormal stiff type of moro is seen in
kernicterus.
Brachial palsy produces an asymmetric moro.
In this example, the paralysis is on the left.
The right arm produces a normal moro response,
while the left arm fails to participate.
The tone of the neck, trunk, and limbs has
been evaluated during the previous examinations.
It may be tested further by manipulation of
the limbs.
[The baby's limbs are extended to examine
the way he reacts.]
The baby should also be suspended in the supine,
lateral, and prone position
on the examiner's hand.
Opisthotonos, as in this case of kernicterus,
is best appreciated in the milder cases
if the baby is placed on its side and attention
directed at retraction of the head.
In more severe cases there may be hypertonus
in all postures.
Universal hypotonia is one of the most striking
signs of mongolism in the newborn.
Congenital contractures and limitations of
motion are striking in this case
of arthrogryposis multiplex congenita.
This baby also has club feet, which are treated
by strapping.
Completely flaccid legs with absent movement
are seen with myelomeningocele.
Trans-illumination of the head should be carried
out in total darkness with a strong flashlight
fitted with a light-tight seal.
One should attempt to trans-illuminate from
occipit to forehead, against the baby's forehead
and from side to side.
With a flashlight in any of these positions,
but especially anteriorly,
a faint glowing subcutaneous halo around the
circumference of the flashlight is normal.
Larger, irregular, and brighter areas may
show the presence of an abnormality
and indicate further testing.
Side-to-side or back-to-front trans- illumination
when seen from the side opposite the flashlight,
may appear as a total glowing over the entire
head.
Such an extended area is usually due to hydroencephaly.
A normal head, of course, will transmit no
light at all.
The reaction of the pupils to light should
be tested, noting the size of the pupils
before the light is turned on, and the speed
of constriction.
A congenital cataract usually appears as an
obvious opacity in the lens,
although there are several possible forms.
Ophthalmoscopic examination is begun by inspection
of the pupil, cornea, and lens.
And followed by examination of the eye grounds
in the conventional manner.
Mydriatic drops are required for adequate
observation,
and the assistance of a nurse is usually needed.
If the examination has been done as part of
a collaborative study
of the National Institutes of Health, the
last two items on the forum concern conditions
during examination
and opinion as to normality.
That condition has met...the examiner's opinion,
whether or not a satisfactory examination
of this baby was obtained.
The diagnosis is an overall clinical impression
of normality or abnormality.
If a baby is believed normal, in spite of
certain deviations from the usual findings,
these may be indicated in the right-hand column.
Finally, if a diagnosis of abnormality is
based on inability to obtain an expected response
normally present, one should clearly repeat
the observation at the end of the examination,
or preferably on another occasion before concluding
that it cannot be obtained.